(upbeat music)
- [Rebecca] Tesla on Thursday
released the redesigned version
of its Model S luxury sedan
dubbed the Model S Plaid.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
The vehicle is priced
starting around $130,000,
capable of going zero to 60 miles per hour
in less than two seconds.
- You know, why make this really fast car
that's crazy fast and everything.
And I think there is something
that's quite important
to the future of sustainable energy,
which is that we've got to show
that an electric car is
the best car, hands down.
(audience applauding)
- [Rebecca] Model S Plaid
has a redesigned interior
that features three display screens.
The vehicle has some
unusual characteristics
including a yoke shaped steering wheel.
- It really feels like,
okay, we're in 2021. Great.
- [Rebecca] The idea behind
redesigns such as this one
typically is to drum up
renewed customer interest.
Automakers have long done this.
- So, let's deliver some cars. All right.
(audience applauding)
- [Rebecca] And this is just another sign
that Tesla in some ways has transformed
from a startup to an
established manufacturer.
Chief Executive, Elon Musk said
he thought the Model S Plaid
would be in customer hands in February,
but found the overhaul to be
more difficult than expected
because of issues such
as ensuring the battery
and the revamped model is safe.
The delay has meant that
Tesla has largely missed out
on what's been a booming
market for luxury vehicles
in the first months of this year.
Tesla is facing increasing
amounts of competition
from startups and legacy automakers alike
that are pouring money into developing
their own electric models.
The hope for Tesla is that this refresh
spurs renewed interest
in one of its classics.
(bright music)